bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition d'en quête d'europe nous sommes
à l'hôtel de coulanges dans le marais à
paris à la maison de l'europe et dans
cette émission nous ferons un zoom sur
les frontières de l'union européenne des
frontières mouvantes qu'ils suscitent
régulièrement la polémique
la turquie par exemple qui cherche à
intégrer l'union depuis déjà quelques
dizaines d'années où la croatie qui
vient de faire son entrée au 1er juillet
dernier mais avant de nous rendre à
split et à istanbul direction athènes la
grèce avec florence maurice un pays qui
a maintes fois failli quitter les
frontières de l'union
florence il ya un pays dont on a
plusieurs reprises annoncé la sortie
imminente de la zone euro c'est bien la
grèce alors pourquoi un énième reportage
sur cette crise alors c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu beaucoup de reportages en grèce on
a beaucoup parlé de crise de crise
économique de crise politique de crise
sociale
on a voulu voir quelle était la crise
morale et psychologique qui touche
également la société grecque c'est vrai
que quand on arrive dans les rues
d'athènes
il ya beaucoup de gens qui viennent nous
voir pour nous parler de cette crise de
la manière d'anti sont touchés de leurs
difficultés quotidiennes
et puis les gens qui sont épargnés
beaucoup m'ont dit on n'ose même plus
dire que on s'en sort correctement
autour de nous tant le climat général
est morose mais plus grave que ces
constatations le taux de suicides en
grèce a explosé en 2011 la progression a
été de 26%
voilà c'est très inquiétant c'est la
plus forte progression depuis 50 ans
donc on vous suit dans les rues
d'athènes à la rencontre de cette
population
6 avril 2012 un pharmacien retraité
criblé de dettes se suicident à deux pas
du parlement grec
un geste politique pour dénoncer
l'austérité c'est une monde c'est une
grande honte cela aurait pu être l'un
d'entre nous ça aurait pu être quelqu'un
de notre famille si ça continue nous
allons tous nous suicider les grecs
prennent soudain conscience de la crise
morale qui secoue leur pays a écrit zoo
une association des de surendettés on a
pris très tôt la mesure de ce malaise
ici 25 juristes bénévoles viennent en
aide aux victimes des coupes budgétaires
bonjour on va voir où en est votre
dossier mariana a poussé la porte en
ce à l époque je me sentais coupable
extrêmement n'ont pas peur je me disais
que j'avais fait beaucoup d'erreurs
j'étais totalement désespéré je ne
sortais plus de la maison je ne voulais
plus me battre je pleurais tout le temps
j'étais envahi par la tristesse et une
profonde envie d'autodestruction parmi
les personnes suivies avec piso quatre
se sont déjà suicidé
les bénévoles ou même dû faire appel à
des psychologues pour les aider à
soutenir les plus désespérés comme
beaucoup mariana se croyait à l'abri
elle était fonctionnaire un emploi
stable bien payé aujourd'hui elle ignore
si elle pourra garder cet appartement
acheté à crédit
après des années de croissance
insouciante en grèce la crise a fait
vaciller ses certitudes europe kavanagh
cana en fait je n'ai rien fait de fou
j'ai juste agi comme tout le monde il
faut se souvenir qu'à cette époque là
les banques nous envoyait des offres de
prêts tous les jours si marianne a
refait surface grâce au soutien
psychologique reçu avec piso beaucoup
n'ont pas cette chance dans une grèce
très religieuse le suicide reste un
sujet tabou
consultez est une décision difficile
coûteuse aussi le secteur de la santé
est à l'agonie un tiers des grecs n'a
plus d'assurance maladie ce centre
médical a été créé en 2011 pour répondre
à l'urgence
on n'a pas d'une écologue aujourd'hui
elle en djoudi ici des médecins
bénévoles se relaie pour offrir
gratuitement soins et médicaments aux
exclus du système de santé s'avère très
loquace et merci beaucoup maria et
psychologue elle consulte ici cinq
heures par semaine je sens qu'il ya
vraiment des choses qui se sont
débloquées en moi ici tous les jours on
voit arriver des bébés de 2 kg alors
qu'ils devraient peser quatre sauts il
en met beaucoup de gens considèrent le
soutien psychologique comme un luxe dans
ce cas ou bien on est en train de
fabriquer une génération de grecs
désemparés et en colère de vider la
geneste tout son potentiel de toutes ses
capacités je n'exagère pas c'est un
génocide
en deux ans la consommation
d'antidépresseurs a bondi en grèce celle
de drogue aussi tout comme les
contaminations au vih
deux fois par semaine place omonia
médecins du monde accueille les
toxicomanes donner les premiers soins de
la grèce a même sa nouvelle drogue
l'a6a composé de liquide de batterie et
de détergents j'ai des amis qui entraîne
régulièrement en deux ans d'utilisation
ils sont plus atteints que moi après 20
ans d'héroïne
je suis déjà allé les voir chez eux ils
deviennent fous il se tape la tête
contre les murs c'est totalement irréel
avoir 2 euros le shoot contre 7 pour de
l'héroïne
l'a6a est la drogue de la crise tous les
indicateurs sont au rouge
mais la grèce s'accroche à ses valeurs
refuges famille et religion depuis le
début de la crise
le père thomas est sur tous les fronts
il a triplé ses distributions de
nourriture et multiplie les activités à
destination des enfants
une fois qu'on aura dépassé la crise je
crois que la situation sera meilleure
car en est
des familles car à cause des difficultés
les gens ont dû renoncer à
l'individualisme absolue et renouer avec
la solidarité c'est quelque chose qu'on
avait perdu après six années de
récession
la grèce espère une timide reprise
économique en 2014
mais nul ne sait encore combien de temps
ou de génération il faudra pour réparer
la crise morale qui mine le pays france
on voit bien dans votre reportage la
question du suicide est tabou en grèce
mais ce que la crise a fait sauter des
barrières oui c'est vrai la question du
suicide est tabou à l'église orthodoxe
est très puissante en grèce et elle
condamne fermement le suicide au point
que les familles ont tendance à déguiser
les suicide en mort accidentelle
mais en cette période de crise l'église
est obligé de faire un petit peu des
concessions en coulisses et un prêtre
m'a dit que de plus en plus souvent ils
fermaient les yeux
il faut dire qu'il ya eu des suicides
très médiatique en grèce comme celui
qu'on a vu dans le reportage qui ont
obligé les grecs à ouvrir les yeux
beaucoup de médecins m'ont dit que les
gens comparé la situation à une guerre
mais avec un ingrédient supplémentaire
dans cette guerre la culpabilité
les grecs ont été montrés du doigt
pendant des mois des années par l'europe
entière et il ya eu une forme de
culpabilité à l'échelle collective qui a
fait beaucoup beaucoup de mal à la
société et florence l'amputation
successifs des budgets de la santé n'a
rien arrangé j'imagine non effectivement
un le secteur en plus c'était déjà très
mal en point avant la crise si on prend
le secteur de la santé mentale assez
moins 40% du budget en 2012
donc concrètement sur le terrain ça
signifie que pour les gens par exemple
qui allaient dans des centres
médico-sociaux adossés à des mairies la
plupart ont fermé ce qui reste ouvert il
ya un psychologue qui obligé de faire le
travail de trois personnes
donc les gens ont comme solution soit
d'aller dans des dispensaires ou quand
ils ont encore la sécurité sociale
d'attendre des mois avant d'être reçu
dans des hôpitaux
et puis plus généralement il ya en grèce
un énorme problème d'accès aux
médicaments
il faut savoir que dans les hôpitaux
publics il ya des centaines de
médicaments qui sont déjà plus
disponible
florence vous montrez bien aussi que le
taux de contamination
yach a explosé oui il a tout simplement
doublé depuis 2008 et 2008 c'est
justement la date à laquelle le
gouvernement grec a arrêté tous ses
programmes d échanges de seringue
puisque ces contaminations touche
essentiellement des toxicomanes et l'
oms a également mis le doigt sur la
réapparition de nouvelles maladies comme
le paludisme par exemple qui avait
disparu depuis 40 ans en grèce et puis
pensons par exemple à un père ou une
mère de famille qui n'a plus les moyens
de faire vacciner ses enfants
on voit que les effets de ces coupes et
de cette crise pourrait être très
important sur le long terme
donc en gros l'austérité est mauvaise
pour la santé oui l'austérité est
mauvaise pour la santé et même
l'austérité tu il ya d'ailleurs un
économiste david stuckler qui a publié
un livre avec ce titre très éloquent une
sorte de pavé dans la mare david
stuckler fait deux constats premièrement
le prix à payer des cures d'austérité
imposées à la grèce se comptent en vies
humaines et le coup un de ces politiques
d'austérité sur le long terme est
beaucoup plus important que si on avait
par exemple conserver les programmes de
prévention donc à c'est évidemment une
critique frontale des politiques menées
et imposé par les bailleurs
internationaux en grèce
et pas seulement en grèce merci florence
merci ce 1er juillet la croatie est
devenu le 28e pays de l'union européenne
un pays qui traverse sa troisième année
de récession et qui compte beaucoup sur
l'europe pour sortir de son marasme
économique
jérôme rabier s'est rendu à split dans
le sud du pays
jérôme cette entrée de la croatie dans
l'union européenne au 1er juillet c'est
la fin d'une longue négociation c'est la
fin d'un long processus puisque la
croatie était candidate dès 2003 les
négociations vraiment commencé en 2005
ça a été long mais ce que la croatie
devait faire des efforts notamment en
matière de lutte contre la corruption
des critères économiques également qu'il
devait remplir c'est aussi
l'aboutissement d'une promesse puisque
l'union européenne avait appelé les
anciennes républiques d'ex yougoslavie à
la fin de la guerre en 1995 à venir
rejoindre l'union européenne après la
slovénie en 2004 la croatie est le
second pays à venir
d'autres pourraient suivre comme la
serbie le monténégro et pourquoi pas le
kosovo mais est-ce qu'on peut
véritablement parler d'un sentiment
européen d'un engouement pour l'europe
en croatie il ya naturellement un
engouement européen de la part des
croates puisque beaucoup d'entre eux
sont allés travailler en italie en
allemagne en autriche en france
mais cette longue procédure d'adhésion à
quelque peu émoussé ce sentiment
européen
en témoigne la faible participation lors
du référendum d'adhésion qui a lieu en
2012 -2 45% des croates s'étaient
déplacés pour voter
donc là on vous suit à split en dalmatie
dans le sud de la croatie
avec ses 1800 km de littoral son
patrimoine culturel laisser vieille
ville conserver la croatie a tout du
décor idéal de carte postale
à deux heures de paris en avion la
région de la dalmatie et sa capitale
split font figure de destination rêvée
pour les européens en quête de soleil de
balades touristiques
on a quand même ici un magnifique
panorama sur split sur cette forteresse
de clis deux fois millénaire des travaux
de réhabilitation sont en cours avec
l'aide de fonds de préadhésion que la
croatie touche depuis quelques années
les travaux ont commencé il y a trois
ans environ avec cette portion murale
qui était totalement démolies maintenant
il travaille à l'intérieur et en os il
est prévu d'installer la salle d'accueil
du préfet de la région
le joug panne pour la réception des
délégations étrangères
et là en dessous ce sera le musée de la
dalmatie par mois
pour cette ville historique qu'est clis
c'est vraiment très important d'avoir pu
commencer la rénovation de la forteresse
et nous espérons poursuivre avec les
fonds européens une fois notre entrée
dans l'union européenne
vraiment effective comme on dépend du
tourisme
ça va permettre de développer des
magasins de souvenirs des cafés des
restaurants car la situation économique
est ici comme dans toute l'europe
pas vraiment au beau fixe
en récession depuis 2009 la croatie
compte sur son entrée dans l'union
européenne et les fonds qui en découlent
pour enfin rebondir
le tourisme est le principal moteur
économique du pays ils représentent
presque 20% du pib
alors c'est naturellement vers ce
secteur que la quasi totalité des
financements seront orientées
l'un des projets consistent à développer
la capacité d'accueil touristique mais
aussi à créer quatre écoles de formation
hôtelière dans la région dalmate
on renforcera ainsi notre attractivité
avec la crise actuelle
on n'a pas de quoi financer ses projets
nous attendons donc vraiment que
l'europe nous aident pour ses projets
d'importance stratégique
une attente forte mais qui a aussi ses
contreparties
la croatie a dû répondre aux exigences
de bruxelles pour intégrer l'union
européenne première exigence l'ouverture
à la concurrence et la fin des
subventions directes
les chantiers navals autres secteurs
importants de l'économie croate sont les
premiers concernés les autorités ont
alors choisi la privatisation totale du
secteur à split
un seul repreneur s'est présentée la
société dit va racheter l'intégralité du
chantier pour cinq cent mille euros
une bouchée de pain yves était et est la
seule chance de reprise pour la survie
de l'activité
donc on a fait beaucoup d'efforts durant
cette période de privatisation on a
rempli toutes les obligations et trois
fois
la commission européenne a approuvé
notre plan de restructuration
donc on est très satisfait de cela au 31
mai dernier la quasi totalité des 3500
salariés ont été licenciés
seuls 2000 seront réembauchés
mais pas nécessairement au même salaire
une casse sociale qui désespère les
ouvriers ici le taux de chômage dépasse
les 20% genre mais ça me fait vraiment
de la peine
après 29 ans de travail là bas je vois
comment les travailleurs et notamment
les plus anciens résonne et on sent
clairement grandir le sentiment de
révolte en révolte
les travailleurs ne comprennent pas
pourquoi le gouvernement croate accepte
toutes les exigences de la commission
européenne
il pense qu'il aurait dû respecter la
position de ces travailleurs de ses
citoyens
car on peut dire que la région dépendent
la construction navale et de ce chantier
en particulier une situation sociale qui
peut expliquer le peu d'engouement des
croates lors du référendum d'adhésion à
l'union européenne en 2012 -2 45%
d'entre eux s'étaient déplacés pour
voter
vingt ans après la guerre de yougoslavie
ce jeune pays de 4 millions d'habitants
reste imprégnée de référence
nationaliste il faudra du temps avant de
voir naître un véritable sentiment
européen
jérôme on le voit bien dans votre
reportage la croatie est rentré dans
l'union européenne et pourtant il reste
encore des efforts à faire
oui la croatie doit et devra encore
faire des efforts
la commission européenne les a déjà
averti une procédure pour déficit
excessif pourrait être engagée si des
efforts de redressement ne sont pas
faits le déficit croate pourrait
atteindre 4,7 pour cent cette année loin
des 3% exigés par bruxelles et pour les
compagnies d'état encore posséder par
l'état croate
il faudra des mesures de restructuration
on l'a vu pour les chantiers navals dans
le sujet mais la compagnie aérienne
croatie airlines le secteur ferroviaire
la poste les autoroutes pour être
concerné presque un tiers des emplois
dans ces secteurs pourraient être
supprimés d'ici 2015
effectivement jérôme l'économie croate
est en récession depuis maintenant trois
ans mais il continue de miser
exclusivement sur le tourisme alors est
ce une bonne idée
alors pour se rendre compte du poids du
tourisme en croatie il ya un chiffre à
retenir ses 12 millions de visiteurs en
2012 pour un pays qui non seulement 4,2
millions d'habitants c'est vraiment
considérable
c'est un secteur qu'ils portent
l'économie croate à bout de bras alors
c'est presque naturel de miser là dessus
alors après il ya un risque c'est en
période de crise économique et notamment
qui frappe durement l'europe s'il
pourrait y avoir moins de voyageurs
notamment allemands français italiens
qui irait sur les côtes croates est là
pour l'économie du pays
ça serait vraiment traumatique merci
jérôme merci laurent s'il ya bien un
pays qui attend depuis des années son
intégration à l'union européenne c'est
bien la turquie les négociations ont
débuté dans les années 60 et sont
aujourd'hui quasi au point mort alors
les turcs regarde-t-il toujours vers
l'union européenne
c'est ce que nous avons voulu savoir
fabrice qu'une s est rendu à istanbul
fabrice vous vous êtes rendus à istanbul
est-ce que les turcs regarde encore vers
l'europe alors on a on a fait le choix
d'aller rencontrer ces turcs qui croient
encore à l'europe et c'est un choix
compliqué parce que de plus en plus les
turcs n'ont plus confiance dans l'union
européenne 65% des moins de 50 ans n'ont
clairement pas confiance dans l'union
européenne
c'est un sentiment européen qui était
pourtant très important il ya encore
quelques années
et puis il y a une forme de lassitude
qui s'est installée particulièrement
chez les jeunes qui ont toujours entendu
parler de l'europe mais c'est plutôt
d'un miracle européens aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt le mirage européen pour pour ces
jeunes générations et pour les turcs en
général donc on vous suit à istanbul
istanbul la plus européenne des villes
de turquie
un carrefour de cultures un pied sur le
vieux continent et la tête en asie ici
l'idée d'une adhésion à l'europe prend
parfois tout son sens
l'entreprise de mouradia ça en est une
parfaite illustration
sa spécialité les arômes pour
l'industrie alimentaire écossais
allemands autrichiens
on a beaucoup donné dans cette usine
donc si vous voulez on est gentil on a
formé notre propre communauté européens
ici avant avant que l'accueil qu'ils
adhèrent à la
si la turquie ne fait pas partie de
l'union des accords existent déjà en
matière douanière ou comme ici en
matière sanitaire dans ces flacons des
centaines d'arômes tous aux normes
européennes alors l'adhésion à l'europe
moore atias à y croire il faut décider
si l'europe c'est une europe
roos antique chrétien ou c'est une
europe qui est prête à partager ses
voyages avec la candidate tulle tic qui
attendent
l'adhésion à l'europe si la donne l'urne
était témoin julie j quoi
l'honnêteté de l'europe l'adhésion à
l'union en turquie peu de gens y croient
encore
et particulièrement la jeune génération
dans un récent sondage 62% des 16-30 ans
n'ont plus confiance pour berra mais ses
amis
la question fait débat il ya du pour et
du contre
on ne peut pas vraiment le dire avant
mais je pense que nous devons intégrer
l'europe et ensuite on verra bien non
non moi je ne veux pas je suis contre
l'entrée dans l'europe
je suis né en allemagne donc je sais ce
que ça signifie de vivre dans un pays
européen
il ya la crise économique le chômage a
augmenté avec l'euro et on a perdu du
pouvoir d'achat
je pense que la turquie n'a pas besoin
de l'europe
au contraire c'est la zone euro qui a
besoin de nous je pense que si on arrête
les négociations aujourd'hui c'est
l'europe qui viendra frapper à notre
porte
ce processus a vraiment été trop lente
les premières discussions ont débuté
dans les années 60 une longue procédure
que certaines universités explique dans
des cours de droit et d'histoire
européen
le professeur steve kean gürsel est
directeur de l'un de ces départements le
problème de la turquie ne sait pas qui
sont musulmans mais ce qu'ils soient
trop blanc dans le passion disent aussi
trop grand trop pauvre mettant en 10
mois entre eux profitent sans donner la
situation en europe et vu le progrès et
la croissance en turquie etc
mais il est trop grand il reste trop
grand et on n'y peut rien en clair la
turquie dans l'union ce serait plus de
députés que la france et presqu'autant
que l'allemagne alors trop grand ou trop
musulman
une chose est sûre lassé d'attendre le
pays se tournent de plus en plus vers
les pays du golfe à m'excuser a ses
entrées à bruxelles pour ce chef
d'entreprise
si l'avenir de son pays est à l'est il
n'y voit pas un frein à une adhésion pib
c'est important pour la turquie de
s'imposer comme le pays phare de la
région
d'un autre côté sont tout aussi
intéressants pour l'europe avec
d'intégrer dans l'union la thur guillot
et son influence locale
si les médias turcs eux sont
eurosceptiques un journal fait de la
résistance et défend l'idée d'une
adhésion
donc ça c'est une idée de
l'interview pour numéro 100 mais pour la
rédactrice en chef
l'europe fait le jeu du pouvoir
conservateur en place en turquie en
freinant les négociations un jeu
dangereux
depuis plusieurs années il n'y a qu'un
seul chapitre iv et les autres les plus
importants ce qui permet une intégration
effectifs sont bloqués donc ça c'est en
fin de compte c'est quelque chose à
double tranchant d'une part ça donne un
très bon prétexte pour le pouvoir en
place en 10 ans on voyait c'est pas nous
c'est eux parce que si nous bloque et
d'autre part quelque part ça les arrange
aussi parce qu'en fin de compte ont
obligé leurs objectifs n'est pas
véritablement de faire des avancées
rapides pour les partisans d'une turquie
européenne
l'adhésion donnerait des garanties pour
l'avenir démocratique du pays
un droit de regard pas forcément du goût
du pouvoir en place
dernier signe d'agacement le premier
ministre erdogan a récemment fixé un
ultimatum à l'europe
la question devrait être tranchée d'ici
à 2023
fabrice on le voit bien dans votre
reportage les turcs d'aujourd'hui ne
regardent plus vers l'europe mais plutôt
vers l'asie et vers les pays du golfe
comment expliquer ce rejet c'est un
rejet qui est très marquée chez les
jeunes qu'on a pu rencontrer chez les
jeunes stambouliote que l'on a rencontré
les serge et qui s'explique par une
chose principale c'est l'aspect
économique
l'europe est en crise la turquie vis un
vrai boom économique
du coup le sentiment général c'est de
dire c'est pas à nous de venir vous
chercher mais plutôt l'inversé à vous de
venir maintenant profiter notre
dynamisme économique profiter de cet
élan que nous avons économiquement on
n'a aucun intérêt à intégrer l'union
européenne pourquoi on viendrait se
greffer à une union qui en grande
difficulté avec cette crise évidemment
que l'on connaît du coup ce qui était
vrai il ya encore quinze vingt ans de
dire la turquie peut profiter
économiquement d'une adhésion
c'est évidemment beaucoup moins vrai
aujourd'hui et donc ceux qui défendent
l'idée d'une turquie européenne
ils la défendent pour des raisons
démocratiques pour des raisons de droits
de l'homme pour pour ce pur pour
s'assurer
les conditions d'une démocratie turque
bien vivante bien réelle surtout qu' il
y a déjà des échanges économiques
faciliter notamment par l'union
douanière exactement depuis une
vingtaine d'années les échanges
commerciaux entre la turquie et l'union
européenne sont facilitées du coup ça
perdrait pour eux sa perte de sens de
d'adhérer puisque déjà toutes les
marchandises peuvent circuler librement
mais c'est tout le paradoxe des
relations de la turquie avec l'union
européenne c'est que les marchandises
circulent librement mais on est tout
autrement des hommes qui ont évidemment
de grandes difficultés pour aller en
europe et fabrice j'imagine que les
polémiques incessantes autour d'une
possible intégration de la turquie dans
l'union européenne la roche derrien
c'est sûr c'est sûr qu'ils se sentent
rejetés par les principaux pays
européens lors de son dernier
déplacement angela merkel en son
déplacement en turquie envers et merkel
a dit mme l'adhésion sera un long chemin
mais je me montre sceptique
ce genre de déclarations a des effets
désastreux dans l'opinion publique
turque
ils se sentent mal aimés c'est un peu
moins vrai aujourd'hui vis-à-vis n'da
france avec l'élection de françois
hollande qui a un peu assoupli la
position de la france vis-à-vis de la
turquie mais clairement l'opinion turque
est les turcs se sentent rejetés mal
aimé du coup cette confiance dans
l'union européenne a évidemment chuté et
il faudrait que le discours politiques
européens évoluent pour faire changer
les choses
fabrice depuis votre reportage de
nombreuses manifestations ont éclaté à
istanbul contre le gouvernement aviez
vous senti ce vent de fronde
alors c'est difficile de parler de vent
de fronde ni même de colère en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y avait une
vraie inquiétude particulièrement chez
les jeunes
pourquoi parce que le
il ya une vraie tentation pour le
pouvoir en place une tentation de
certain autoritarisme et évidemment la
jeune génération turcs très attaché à la
démocratie
s'inquiète et donc si le style motif de
la contestation peut paraître futile vu
d'europe
il est assez symbolique d'une inquiétude
qui grandit parmi la population et parmi
les jeunes stambouliote
mais je rappelle que c'est donc un parc
dont les arbres aurait été rasée pour
des constructions mais est ce que c'est
la même chose est-ce que c'est là dans
le reste du pays
le problème est le pouvoir joue là
dessus c'est que istanbul et à part en
turquie
c'est l'avis des intellectuels la ville
des étudiants et la contestation n'est
pas n'est pas suivie au delà ou très
très difficilement suivis au-delà
d'istanbul le pouvoir joue là dessus et
pour les des contestataires pour les
opposants c'est très compliqué de se
faire entendre
merci fabrice c'est la fin de cette
émission à la maison de l'europe à paris
nous on se retrouve très vite sur public
sénat et tous les jours sur
publicsenat.fr
ce texte sera